I'm gonna fight you I'm sorry what  parking lot after school its own  teachers don't fight I want everybody to  see this  hashtag teacher fight course knows not  this I don't need to be liked  I need to educate  I just don't know the first thing about  fighting makeup first  are you serious list of 1700s  maybe the best thing to do is just run  I never said known about no running  who's you see this game flex high in  plexi just nothing there why just take  punch and then just go down played ads  like possums do or anything that's like  a like a [ __ ] animal got my mom what's  your word  there's a crazy guy at my high school  he's trying to beat me up if you have a  problem with a bully I need to speak to  a teacher I am a teacher your gold me  not gonna take that ass-whooping  you